yeah so I get asked a lot about how you
set my first name so much so that
actually on my website there's a little
wave file you can click and listen to
that if you want to but for all
intensive purposes I've just go by bank
oh yeah so thanks so much for having
having me here today I'm super excited
excited to be here and to talk to you
guys about the stuff that I do so I come
from a land up in Puget Sound area a
microsoft research it's an in redmond
and i've been there for about six years
prior to that i did a lot of augmented
reality work i spend good portion of my
PhD years wearing a head worn display
walking around like a zombie and and now
since i joined microsoft I've been doing
dealing with some of the similar
concepts but dealing them to slightly
different means as Michael said mostly
projectors and cameras but fundamentally
I'm interested in how do you extend the
interaction vocabulary how do you
understand extend the interaction
bandwidth to communicate between humans
and computers in a sense try to look at
not so much replacing the the
interesting in good ways that we already
have with you know our input devices but
how do you extend that with with new
sensing capabilities new sensing
modalities to to make the interaction
with computers less digital in a form
and more analog or more analog to the
real world but in analog in nature not
so much on and off as much as kind of
gestural and expressive that with the
way that we have the dexterity in our
hands and our bodies to interact with
the physical world we've been trying to
look at the same methods to do that and
to apply that to the digital content now
the first project that I did was when
joining microsoft this is just a little
preview there it's just creating a funky
little I would say a toy where we've
started with at that point this was
before the iphone and for all these are
four things you know the table tops were
all the rage so we did a spherical
surface just to make a just to make a
point that we can make kind of turn any
any shape into interactive display so
that's fun
after that I did see even more ludicrous
things like churning churning a dome
into a fully interactive dome so this is
kind of like your instant planetarium
you have a blow-up dome you have a
little projector in the middle and not
only can you do that but literally by
just putting your hand in front of the
projector and moving things around in
midair you're literally navigating
through the stars and exploring all the
stuff needless to say this is a really
popular demo we actually showed it to KY
we showed it a bunch of different places
kids loved it you have multiple people
kind of enjoying the space and it's
really easy and interactive all you
really do is like reach in front of the
projector and move this thing around but
with this little pinching gesture all
right also as part of it I've built a
bunch of cardboard domes so if any of
you need some instructions for burning
man for how to build some of these
geodesic domes all you need is
paperclips and cardboard and you get
some really nice rigid structures like
this as long as you're willing to spend
some time cutting this precisely so
anyway it's a lot of fun so the black
parts are there where the two cardboard
we wanted to have a really dim dome
inside so we actually put a piece of
black paper just folded it over the fold
and put paper clips on top of it to hold
it so that there's no light leakage it's
not actually structure on no that's just
a cold piece of black paper yeah good
question Oh thing throughout this whole
talk I really like audience
participation so if you guys have any
questions feel don't feel free to raise
them right up front we don't really need
to wait until you know the end of the
talk here if you're shy you can come and
talk to me afterwards as well I
understand there's both types of people
as Michael said so as part of part of
the great thing about working at
microsoft research or in pretty much in
any industrial research lab is that
there is a conduit for for your ideas
and for your for your thinking to make
it into products and to have other
people use it so I've worked as as you
know as part of microscope resurgent and
is part of product teams I worked in
several different things including the
old surface model and the Microsoft
touch mouse which stem directly from our
waste paper
called mouse to point oh I spent a year
with the product team making that that's
actually a first device and pretty much
the only device right now that allows
you to have a curved capacitive sensing
device so device is sensitive to both
gripping and gesturing and the same
surface is used for both in many other
cases by the the industrial design of
the device you design it so that where
you're holding the device is not
actually triggering any input in this
particular device where you're holding
and how you're holding it it's all part
of a sensitive surface and we need to do
some smart interesting based on our your
touches currently being used for
gripping or are they being used for
interaction which makes it challenging
but also quite quite interesting because
you can use the full dexterity of your
hand to interact also the same thing
that the microscope touch mouse ended up
doing the touch cover the surface covers
a lot of different cross pollination and
a lot of different venues for for
removing this kind of research into
products but what I'm going to talk to
you today is this idea of how do you how
do you turn any surface in your
environment into our interactive surface
which is something that I've been
thinking about a lot over the last five
six years and I want to I like to start
with this idea of showing you the
devices of today now I belong to a
certain company and you can pick any
company you want and substitute the
images here but in general what you are
faced with today is this idea that
you're interacting and most of it is
flat rectilinear 2d screens most of the
content that you're interacting with is
also that nature they are say there's
some 3d stuff but in general you're
dealing with data with 2d things and
also the interactive surfaces are kind
of mostly planar you know this kind of
2d in that in that sense as well same
thing goes for the phone where the
actual screen is having a dual duty
there it has serves both as an input and
an output area but again flat
rectangular digital space in many ways I
find it not much different then you know
this image is 1963 I've been southern
Alaska
in many ways you have a flat rectangular
screen mostly 2d and you have some
keyboard and mouse you know cut miles at
that point but because I'm gonna have
some keyboard input it actually has a
pen input which is maybe making a
resurgence again right we might see a
lot of that stuff definitely a the
surface pro the best that I have used it
has a stylist built-in but in many ways
that the fundamental nature of the way
that we most consumed the information
and the digital devices in the way that
we most interact with them has not
really changed that much touch i think
is a big step but it gets is just a step
in that direction i I believe we're
seeing the display is becoming much more
than verse recently there's now smaller
bigger higher resolution brighter
visible in sunlight 3d interactive all
the kind of stuff but more interesting
these to all these commercial ones are
some of these ones that are coming up
such as flexible holographic if you can
guys check out there's couple companies
right now one one of them is zebra
imaging that I showed roaring pictures
here that are working on fully
interactive holographic 3d displays to
really hold a huge potential but they're
just in an infancy but it's really it's
really interesting as well as ephemeral
these are these are really fun to think
about you know fog screens or this is a
display that where they turn the
basically surface of a bubble it's a
colloidal display as an actual
projection surface is an actual
interactive surface it's really fun they
demoed it is significant couple years
ago 2012 right but anyway what all of
that is kind of pointing in my mind is
that I believe that we will be if not
we're already kind of there we will be
able to basically transform any surface
of any object into into a display
fundamentally also there's another trend
that's helping this this this idea and
that is the the rise of digital
fabrication and the fact that we can
manufacture things in a in a in case
them in a much more simple and automatic
way together with with this transition
in the displays and being basically over
variety of shapes I think all of a
sudden we can start thinking about
changing the nature of every single
surface in and and making that a part of
the interactive digital vocabulary but
fundamentally interactions I still think
are not keeping up we live in very
visually rich environments on the on the
computer but I like thinking about the
the interaction part still being stuck
in primarily buttons movements some
stuff would connect fundamentally the
way that the interactions work is they
reduce the the expressivity of your body
into into a very few variables and
mostly on/off states or even in the case
of connect the way that you really
interact is they reduce the whole body
into 23 points in space so it's 23
points in space represent everything
that they know about you pretty much
it's it's a huge reduction of
dimensionality it allows for creating a
Content on it but it loses the dexterity
it loses the expressiveness loses the
analog feeling a lot of these
interactions I love this picture because
this is I i firmly believe this is know
how the computer really sees us there's
a one I most things are not stereo
there's two years you can kind of hear
two sides stereo audio and and mostly
you have a one big finger for tapping
you might argue this point you have to
if you want to pinch to zoom or do a
couple things but in general you're like
a big finger with an eye the way that I
I think that the way that we should
think about this is really trying to
look at interactions that are richer
that are higher bandwidth and that are
more analog in nature rather than the
digital kind of we are adapting well
ourselves to the nature of how the
computer would like the input to be
rather than the way that we would like
to interact with it so I'll talk to you
today about several different projects
that kind of explore the space and
mostly I know it's kind of tough because
this slot is right after lunch and
mostly people just kind of want to fall
asleep right after lunch so most of
these talks are going to be over videos
and hopefully they'll be engaging enough
to get to see some of the fun stuff now
all of these project actually have a
unifying
thread and that is there they're
fundamentally combination there that are
enabled by a combination of a camera and
a projector in this case a depth camera
a Kinect camera and a projector because
of it basically that's an enablement
technology here and we use those as I
said to kind of enable the interactivity
on any surface or between any surface so
one way to think about this is to look
at this as computational illumination
rather than having lights the way that
are really done right now we are able to
have smart lights that can both sense
the activity of the user in front of
them and actually direct and
individually address different portions
of the of the of the projection area
with different colors we are not the
first ones to be doing this I don't want
to claim that this is an idea that kind
of I invented it's just an idea that I
think it's pretty powerful and we've
we've in contrast to some of this
earlier work which is super
inspirational in kind of the IO bulb or
the office of the future everywhere
displays what we managed to create is
for the first time we have working depth
sensing cameras we have enough
computational technology to actually
start understanding and reasoning about
the larger space so we were for the
first time able to actually create
end-to-end systems that are not super
dependent on predefined spaces on
predefined interfaces and predefined
kind of modeled environments but really
started think about these as how do you
embed them into a space and start
reasoning about them at runtime yes you
should be over laptop right yeah yeah
just a scanner else in the future and
they did a lot of work in that space but
they haven't really produced the office
of the future in that time it was just
it was basically a little bit too far
out given the computational capabilities
of the time and where they were but they
definitely laid the very foundational
work in structured light and and and
kind of sensing approaches there again
it's also one thing that's really really
fascinating to me is lately they've been
this whole area of art
the projection mapping of art is
basically going and taking a very bright
projector and and and doing really fun
stuff on on buildings or you know doing
different illusion and again this is
very related because basically they're
there augmenting the existing reality
and turning it into some new basically
making new effects but one thing that's
very different from our work is that
they completely have complete knowledge
of what the actual environment is that
they're augmenting they're completely
taking every single aspect of it
modeling it and and augmenting it in a
kind of post way so what you're seeing
is basically an art production it's not
a real time system also there's there's
comparable ways to think about the space
in in terms of virtual reality augmented
reality with glasses and many ideas that
I'll be talking about actually
completely relevant in that space I'm
not saying this is better this is in
many ways just different or
complimentary I think one fundamental
difference that you have between any
kind of immersive VR space and what I'm
talking about is that this the the
systems that we've worked with our walk
up and use they don't require you to
wear any extra gear most of the time you
can you're still allowed to basically
reach for real objects you live in
reality you're just surrounded with a
little bit of an enhanced reality rather
than completely replacing what what
reality means as it's done in a kind of
a VR headset way all right so now that
this kind of sets the tone I'll tell you
a little bit about the first project in
this space that we've done a couple
years ago with a colleague of mine Andy
Wilson up at Microsoft Research and the
main idea there is that we put a couple
projectors and couple depth sensing
cameras in the ceiling as a form kind of
a chandelier right there that you see
that right now on the on the screen the
cameras that we use this was prior to
actually releasing the Kinect so this
these are primeSense cameras that came
you know there were there were
prototypes that we use in the lab to
enable us to aggregate all this
information all the 3d structure from
the entire room and map it out into one
single unified space so that week I'll
these projectors
cameras to basically increase coverage
not so much to have much overlap and
then when we combine them all register
them all into one single space where
fundamentally you can start thinking
about designing interfaces not in a
typical way you're not like this pixel
on screen relates to this particular
object but in kind of a mechanical way
like oh I want the menu to be a meter
away from the table down on the floor
and and that is really really really
liberating one thing that you can do is
you can turn any surface into kind of a
multi-touch surface so here I'm showing
your standard desk or a wall and again
with what's interesting there is all
this is performed by a literally
processing depth data in space rather
than having any kind of sensor
augmentation of the surface itself
because we know everything that happens
between surfaces also you can literally
touch the the wall and the table and
make a conduit and transition objects
directly that way we also in view
objects like if you take the picture and
you want to hold in your hand we have it
we give it a little bit of physicality
so literally you can just walk it around
now the system does not actually know
anything about hands or objects it's
just behaves in a kind of physically
realistic way so this ball just ahead
has a little bit of physicality property
knows what gravity is but doesn't want
to make large jumps which allows you to
pick it up with any kind of object it's
not sensitive to having to know is it
your right hand right wrist type of
thing that picks it up or not another
thing that you just saw was you know you
can touch different objects to move up
just around as well as this menu that's
oriented in space so literally if you
reach it in a particular area you end up
having a virtual menu that pops out and
you literally just trigger it that way
that's just something kind of gives you
a sample of how how we do this stuff um
yeah if you don't mind me asking just uh
could you do like because you have a 3d
data of the hands that find enough
resolution that you could then like warp
the projection image so that rather than
look at my flat projection on your hand
is just that's it so in this case we
didn't
I'll show you the next project actually
did exactly that there's a couple of
them so this is this is a couple years
old at this point but this is kind of
the first thinking that we had in that
space and yeah absolutely you can
absolutely do it the menu right now
didn't the menu did want smart thing and
that is that if you if you have a
unified way of thinking about space some
of the tricky things in in in a
collaborative interfaces which is how do
you orient something or what do you do
all of a sudden become trivial because
if you reach into this virtual menu
space and you want to project the label
you can very easily figure out
connectivity and figure out where your
head is like what's the highest point of
that thing and orient the label directly
towards you so if I reach from here the
photo says you know I it's very readable
if I reach from here the photos that
says it's readable room if you reach
right in front of me you get a different
late you get a label that's oriented to
you you kind of get that for free you
don't have to do any kind of extra
sensing extra combination sensor fusion
or anything like that because you can
literally take all the data that that is
depth data that you acquire and and
start reasoning in it in a 3d space this
is another good example ah just messed
it up I don't know where we were here
let's start from here there was another
uh maybe here's dropping it on the
tables did this connectivity for example
if you take one side and put into the
other side it really we're not computing
it again based on any particular
skeletal data but really on 3d
connectivity and space so literally you
can actually go and shake somebody's
hand and move the object directly kind
of close the loop you'll see that in the
next in the next segment I think in this
case we did so we had a little simple
calibration procedure to make the table
and the wall kind of a special surfaces
there here's the idea if you see Andy
and me kind of go there shake hands and
and we can move the picture from the
wall through us through our part now
what enabled us to do this is we we took
three images this is the live feeds for
cameras but are we really difficult to
author these environments if you have to
think about these camera
views so instead of thinking about all
the stuff we basically unified it in a
one unified space and you'll see that
down below so rather than thinking about
three segmented and and you know how
does that how does a particular icon
move from camera to camera B once you
have them unified once you think about
them in there's a 3d space and ends up
being much simpler to to to reason about
that we also do so this is an example
this is kind of a debug view but really
what you're seeing is that as a depth
sensing as well as the kind of
interactivity with these physical
objects and here's kind of you know what
happens with the menu I mean very
straightforward very simple of by
today's standards now it's very noisy
and all the stuff it did improve with
with the actual connect and eventually
it's going to improve even more with the
new version of Connect I this is
interesting because this is basically a
reprojection of depth data from a
perspective of a table you can say like
what is that what is the depth data look
in the segment of the table that is you
know 10 centimeters above it and what
you end up is images that look very
similar to what you would expect in any
any kind of a multi-touch device right
they would they would give you this
tract components and you can literally
map them to a touch-based interface like
that it also gives you a disability 2k6
synthesized virtual cameras you can
create views that are kind of
autographic top-down views of there's no
camera that actually has this particular
view but it is as this gives us a
top-down view of the entire space and
now you can start reasoning about who is
where and where the users and all sorts
of you know who's moving an object in
from one image to another image alright
so the next project in that space is is
basically dealing with some of the
questions that came here in the audience
and that is one of the things that we
wanted to do in in light space the
interactions are very crude like instead
of even having a touch-based
interactions they were mostly based on
blobs and kind of like you know you can
move a picture from here to there but
you can't really interact you can't get
to the dexterity that that you would
normally want that you potential
have on your phone so we created this
project with an intern of our Chris
Harrison from CMU he's now a professor
at CMU he worked with us over the summer
to make to to use a depth camera and a
projector and create interfaces on any
particular surface but they can be
closely approximating the precision that
you have right now on a regular touch
screen so here's the here's the idea
that you're actually the interface is
mapped to a particular surface whatever
surface you end up having and not only
can track a point in space this is a
touch in space but you also get it on
everyone very deformable surface your
hand is a pretty non uniform thing and
also gives you a good hover space so not
only do you know when the finger is
touching but you actually know when
things are above this is a depth step
you from from above the you know the
view from our camera and you see you see
the classification of fingers the way
this is implemented is this particular
piece of hardware at the time which was
a custom-made depth sensing camera
that's a short-range one it worked for
about 10 centimeters to about a meter
combined with a little pico projector
but what it enables you is to literally
walk up to any particular surface and
tap on it and all of a sudden the
information just appears there right so
if you just have a notification you can
just pull up the thing now maybe you
want to find some little bit larger
surface like you walk up to the wall and
I'll just drag out the interface where
you would like to read out that
particular email and maybe you you you
you know you pull up your your hand
again there and now I'm not saying that
dialing phone numbers is actually really
interesting in many in many ways I think
it's kind of an outdated idea but what's
interesting about that is that the
precision of our sensor is actually good
enough to tap these small tiny buttons
we found that it's actually close enough
to the precision of the regular touch
screen on the phone here's an idea of
you know doing the same thing on on kind
of having a scrolling menu on your hand
and literally in this case we the way
the reason why this works is because we
we have a very good assumption of where
the camera is looking from everything
comes from your body so you can make
easy assumptions about where the hands
come in and how your fingers look from
that particular perspective so this
gives you a feeling of you know
accurate our system is how responsive so
you can do all sorts of annotations and
things are a little flowy but again
these are just little prototype demos
what's what's really interesting here is
there's a kind of a metaphysical
question here is what is the surface
that you're interacting with and what is
the surface that you're interacting on
in other words what what's what's
touching what because in many ways these
things are in contact so so one thing
that we ended up doing is that we
literally label everything that happens
to be in front of you with the little
tiny blue dots so if you walk up to
something all of a sudden you see a
couple blue dots on candidate surfaces
and at that point where whichever one
you end up touching ends up being the
kind of originating one the first one
that you start from alright so we looked
at these interfaces from kind of a from
a touch perspective like how do you
actually enable interactivity on on a
random deformable surface and now we
started looking at how would you
actually present some three-dimensional
data how would you get content that
moves up away from the surface and still
give you this this direct an
instrumented way of interacting with it
so the next projects called Mirage table
and that was done again following the
the Omni touch work and in this case we
have a 3d stereoscopic projector in the
ceiling and we have a Kinect camera
looking directly at you here what's what
the system is doing is in this case is
literally acting as a 3d mirror so is
digitizes everything that happens to be
in front of the table and on the table
and literally makes a 3d model at
runtime of that particular three of that
particular object now that's cool but
all of a sudden because you're
digitizing everything at what happens on
the table including your hands you can
start running a physical simulation with
that data so literally we are
representing here our hand as a bunch of
proxy particles because if you run a
physical simulation it's it's good to
have a finite volume and finite math if
you have a deformable mesh that kind of
ruins the physics so but you can do
things like this where you can literally
play start playing with virtual
projections in 3d in mid-space with your
free hands because again this system is
digitizing and meshing up the entire 3d
geometry of the scene in front of the
table at runtime it also is doing this
perspective projection so that objects
look correct from your hand you look you
see that you're holding this ball but
really the ball is projected over
multiple surfaces for your eyes to be
doing the same thing another personal
favorite here is then all of a sudden
since you can do this digitization you
can start creating these interfaces
where you have one Lego block and you
can build whole castles of interesting
things and concepts because literally
you're just scanning building moving and
and and playing a little bit of a kind
of CAD work there so it's quite fun to
to do this this all comes together in a
game like this where you literally bring
in a bowling pin scan it and then now
you can use a virtual ball as soon as
you scan that bowling pin in there you
can use the virtual bolts start bowling
with it and knock it down and hopefully
compete against it right so uh the the
the the time from the object being
physical to the object being virtual but
having physical behaviors is literally
shrunk down to an instant we just you
know it's a click of a button or you
know happens all the time we also hooked
up two of these together so you can
literally have a two face to face
conversation almost think about it as 3d
skype not only that you're seeing
somebody but you can actually do things
together you have the same physical
units you can literally shake hands with
somebody in midair you have no
negotiation time because you're seeing
this in 3d you're holding glasses and
you know is you don't feel it you don't
actually have a haptic sensation there
that's something that's really hard and
we keep working on it but we're not
quite there and I don't think we will be
for a long time but but in terms of
knowing exactly where things are and how
do you put this stuff together you
literally have a shared interactive
space with with a zero negotiation or
all the same negotiations that you have
it in physicality as if you were sitting
and talking to somebody across the table
yeah
not bowing strength yes you create a I
guess mass model for copying right let's
go special so the example things that we
assume there it makes a couple
assumptions to make this possible one is
that we don't really scan things from
multiple sides so we really only see one
side of an object so when you scan a
bowling pin you get a front side we just
rotate it and make that make an
assumption that the object is
symmetrical and and fill the bottom so
once you do that we assign a a simple
mass to it that's proportional to its
volume assume basically uniform density
about different objects but we we have
looked at different classification of
objects so looking at you know can you
find and can you index into something
like that this is a duplo block and this
is a bowling pin or some like that so
can you look up the mass rather than
infer it but right now in these demos
it's basically the mass is proportional
to the overall volume and and then
that's also a problem for simulating
physics it with your own hand right
because you're if you're only seeing the
top of your hand you don't you could
potentially have infinite mass this can
go at you know like the depth can go
into infinity so instead of doing that
we really literally represent we do it's
a packing problem we pack it with proxy
particles each little spheres that
represent you know basically fill up the
contour of your body and those spheres
end up being the interacting parts so
they get updated through optical flow
and through the through the basically
the depth information so they get
updated frame to frame and they end up
impacting and they end up being the
interactors in the end of physics seen
all right I'm going to skip all the
experiments you can look at that in the
in the paper another interesting one
after we did all of these ones is how do
you really get can you can you have a
moveable kind of projector camera system
to allow you to really encompass the
whole room like a wave if we wanted to
turn this whole room into into project
but in kind of augmented reality through
projection system can we have a pan tilt
unit that would allow us to do that so
we build a machine called Bhima Tron
we try harder our names to just make
sure that you know they're they're as
good as you can get them to be and the
Bema Tron looks around and it's again a
Kinect camera and a projector 3d
projector and now it tracks you know up
a user in space and can project onto
their hands it can project different
things and I'll show you a couple
different things one is also you can run
this like a little car simulation and
over different geometry in there it
doesn't actually care what the geometry
is in the scene because it looks at you
know this is the depth mash directly and
when it finds people turns on the
skeletal tracking so here you'll see us
doing a little dance just to verify that
it works it's always important to dance
in your videos because that you know
shows that it's not fake we also an
interesting challenge and all of this
stuff is that I'm going to stop this for
a second an interesting challenge in all
this is that if you have a steerable
display that goes looks around that
means that it's at any given time it's
only going to see a certain small
portion of the entire space so if you're
relying only on vision to interact with
it you're basically continuously chasing
it around to try to be in its view so
what we did is we we use the feature of
the Kinect that's not often used in kind
of these hacky connect demos which is
the steerable or a microphone so very
quickly by just placing three of them in
the corners of a room two of them kind
of parallel one vertical you can
basically triangulate person's position
with very little calibration we get down
to about half a meter accuracy of
localization so literally what we do is
you just I'll show you we we literally
are able to call up so there's three
connects here we don't use their actual
depth cameras we just use their race
steering or a microphone and you see the
localization here we also put in the
voice of bladder from portal so it has a
little bit of an attitude beamish Ron
and I was just talking to two Wendy this
morning and it was a it was quite
amazing let me just pause this again it
was quite amazing that's the only kind
of anthropomorphic thing that we added
to be mature on it basically responds to
when it turns just says yeah what and
but it's amazing how much difference
that actually made in a lot of people
coming in there and literally just
engaging with it there's nothing else to
be mature and can say that's it I mean
yeah what is is pretty much the extent
of its vocabulary but even just that
much with the physicality of turning
towards you and shining up and you know
kind of looking at you is enough
completely to to think about it as
almost a real thing versus a device in
the ceiling so that's just an
interesting tidbit there but again
really what be mature and shines at is
this idea that all of a sudden it can
project an object it can respond that
object can can behave in a physically
realistic way so in this case we're
having we're driving an RC car but the
RC car is virtual completely when you're
driving it with a with a physical
steering wheel
so there's a connect steering wheel the
car is projected not the greatest shot
but this is good
now if you had to pre calibrate for this
this is fine but this is all done at
runtime we can literally move this ramp
you know and if you would drive the car
slower the car is going to just flip
over right it responds in the same way
that the real car would write if you
kick it it should flip around it's even
though its projected it has a complete
physical reality that's believable there
we also correct per view right so we try
told you with audio we track where you
are in the room and we just give you the
correct perspective view we can also run
the car in stereo if you want to see it
in 3d but in general we find it more
interesting to just drive it into the
it's it the way that it works is we use
Kinect fusion to literally make the
model of the environment but not also do
to make the model but smooth the model
because think about every single little
bump on the floor if you have to drive a
little RC car over it ends up being
quite a disturbing thing so here you see
how it updates over time right it
literally you can make a new model and
right right over something and that's
exactly what we do we just literally
move things around the lab and drive
over it you can think about driving it
over your car you can think about all
sorts of different things in there to
engage there this is a little homage to
an old demo in computer science called
put that there where we literally what
we're doing is we're scanning people
we're making sure that their skeletal
tracking work and then we give them a
little speech interface they can move
things around and say you know I want
something over there I want it over here
I want to kind of look at some slides
etc so I'll show you you'll see in the
next slide how that in the next clip how
that works put that there now there is
no unified model of the room in this
case it just looks for extends the
trajectory of your hand and looks for
the first available surface where it
could be basically intersecting so you
can keep it there now she's gonna put it
somewhere else and on the floor thing
put that there
again these are goofy examples I'm not
saying this is the best bar to point to
lever but the power of and combinations
that you have when you combine speech
tracking and understanding of what the
geometry of what the room looks like
it's quite a quite mesmerizing you all
of a sudden can do all sorts of funky
stuff like that all right so this also
brings me to another project that's very
recent we did this just last year it's
called illumiroom you might have seen
this but I'll show you just the preview
video just to kind of get us started
maybe we can dim the lights a little bit
xbox go big
now this is what a typical research
video should look like you know if only
you had a budget of you know what
exceeds a lot of people salary anyway
the the interesting thing this was shown
at CES at the beginning of this year and
they wanted to have a really splashy
demo but the honest truth about this is
yes it's a fancy production but none of
it is fake they just literally shot this
in our lab with an actor or actually to
actor the lady and a guy and and and
they shot all the stuff is basically
real they just shot it with a very nice
camera and a very nice setup just
finished for that sorry I know there
were a lot of volunteers who wanted to
be in the video but you know they had to
pick talent to appear right so that was
one of the artistic freedoms that
allowed them to have right like you pick
whoever you want it's fine anyway so all
jokes aside um the the aluminum system
is basically the same components as that
all the systems that I talk to you so
far and and you can see the trend here
but uh but the idea in this particular
project and by the way I have to say
this is project mostly done by an intro
virus Brad Jones from University of
Illinois in urbana-champaign Brett and I
and and other folks have worked on this
project to try to look at how do you
extend the experience of watching
television or playing games on TV right
now into your real living room without
necessarily moving you out of it without
changing physically how your room looks
like or without actually knowing what
your room looks like either right so
some of the same problems that we had in
before and be mature on and Raj table
own and stuff they're all coming back
again in the living room we've made a
conscious design decision to not change
the content on the television in other
words if you don't have a little miram
you get the same feed as everybody else
on the TV so we don't change we don't we
in no way are we ever changing what's
actually strong the screen what we are
trying to do is we are trying to give
you
visuals that are in the periphery that
complement the content and then also in
some cases respond to how your room
looks like in what your room does so the
vision that we had kind of wood the way
that we started is what if you had this
little pro cam system projector camera
system then you pop down on your coffee
table and it automatically finds your TV
and and it just presents you with this
extra view we ended up not putting in a
coffee table we put in a bookshelf
behind it but kind of a similar content
we didn't realize automatic calibration
so that the system is literally
self-calibrating you put it down it fine
it splashes some things on the TV it
finds exactly where the TV is it
splashes some structured light patterns
on the surround it gives you the it
finds find its projectable area and at
that point on the system is completely
kind of self driven it just gets the
feed out and and projects is outside
what's up good question so currently
both of them are run from the same PC so
there's one computer where we literally
play a game we've set the main display
to be the TV we play the game in this
case you know red eclipse or something
else in there and and then we we do a
couple ways of getting the content out
and i'll talk about all those ways a
little bit later on but it currently
it's all the same system it is also
foreseeable there's lots of move in the
industry to have attached screens you
know like xbox for example i have a
smart glass appliance which is basically
you know you can run on your phone you
can run it on a tablet you can write or
whatever and it can get direct video
feeds from the xbox to give you a
company in content in many ways you can
think about illumiroom being a smite
SmartGlass appliance for xbox on you
know there's just not a display of this
kind it's a display of projector kind
right that that augments your additional
display so I want to talk a little bit
about kind of some of the smarts that we
do we compensate in illumiroom both for
your geometry of your room but we also
compensate for appearance of your room
so in other words your room is not just
white furniture on white background on
white carpet all same brdf all same you
know
reflectance properties of your foot of
your of your furniture what it does not
compensate for is situations like this
where you know if you do decide to put
your TV right in front of the window
with some glass stuff in there it's
going to be really hard to do a living
room set up in this particular case
there's no way for me to compensate for
you know going across the street
sunlight and all that kind of stuff but
in general for most people setups you do
end up having conversation what you see
here is this is what our projector is
actually projecting this is what the the
image looks like in the scene so in the
scene we specifically had some white and
black boxes from ikea to kind of not try
to cheat too much and we see how we
compensate for them you can't completely
overpower the nature but you can get
very close so let me the preview video
gave you a whole bunch of illusions all
at once kind of give you a you know as
much shock and awe as you can take I'll
guide you briefly through all the
different design explorations that we
did because we started basically with
this particular one which is basically
you steal a texture from the game and
then you see it projected on the on the
periphery so this game is called red
eclipse and we're just literally playing
it and all the funky all the
functionality of illumiroom in this
setup is just focus plus context right
it gives you a lot wider screen honestly
speaking if that's all you want to do I
would HIGHLY advise you guys to go and
buy a bigger TV because I think in some
ways it's missing the point and that's
what we realized early on even though
it's impressive it's impressing for a
very short time it's not really using it
to the full extent what's up so are the
colors on the outsider and the main TV I
have an example racing game so you can
tell me a little later on how it works
but yes the idea of where your avatar is
Right whether the avatar is car or your
you know your hand holding a gun or some
like that is an interesting one right it
might be too far away and you're not
rendering and all sort of stuff I don't
in in reality I don't actually find we
show this to many many people many
people have plated we showed it at
siggraph this the summer and nobody
really complains about it not being
exactly right so
I don't think it actually would be that
much of a problem but we have a couple
ideas about how to fix it how to make it
more right however we haven't tried as i
said we keep the on-screen content on
screen content we haven't changed at
whatsoever so all we do is change what
happens outside of a TV right now so so
one of the things that you can start
when thinking about these illusions then
did this design space of what happens
around it you can start thinking about
what your i actually sees right so we
started with that we looked at 0 in
periphery of your retina you're much
more much more sensitive to contrast and
edges and contours and not really two
textures and color right so your eye
doesn't even even proceed that so if you
lose all the color and just highlight
the edges you end up having a much more
immersive there's much more peripheral
motion happening in your retina you feel
much more drawn into it even though you
lose a lot of high-frequency tone now of
course that only works if you're
actually there and focusing on the focus
right if your eye starts wandering
around and looking for extra content
then yes you're kind of missing some
stuff around but in these cases it's
very you're playing a game you don't
want to get shot like this is this is
what you're trying to do you're focused
on the screen also with when working
with game designers we had a bunch of
kind of critique sessions in there and
one of the suggestions is very early
came on is like you don't want to bleed
out everything maybe we just want to be
selective about only the content that
really matters so in this case the
explosions the enemies the weapons that
you need to pick up bullet shells things
like that bleed out a TV but everything
else ends up staying within the TV I
think that's particularly powerful right
it kind of gives you this extra sense of
like you know the enemy is coming or
that you I forgot this there's a grenade
back there but other than that you don't
necessarily have to go and be overloaded
with all this extra information we also
this is just a kind of highlight we can
we can basically segment your furniture
segment the experience however we want
to we can find for example where the
back wall is
find the largest vertical surface for
example in this case and then make it
appear like your game is being played on
the back wall that the back wall is the
portal to this other world your
furniture is not and this brings us to
this idea that your furniture it can
somehow be included in the game so one
of the things that that fascinated us
for a long time is that games and TV
shows and pretty much all the content
you see on the television has a distinct
visual language in games that's most
apparent by looking at the shaders that
they apply and the rendering of that
particular game if any of you have ever
played the game called borderlands you
you have this really highly outlined
view and that is kind of the signature
view of that particular game now think
about it you can take that same shader
and apply to reality you can take the
shader and you know make your room look
you know cartoonish or outline make it
look black and white if you're looking
watching film noir or having you know
kind of different different style of the
appearance of your room can match the
on-screen content which which is really
fun because all of a sudden your room
responds correctly and now you can also
start reading messing with people you
can start having these visual illusions
where things are very trippy without
necessarily you know requiring any drugs
do all I'm doing is a sweet reproject
all i'm doing is reproject a little bit
of a texture with some distortions there
those are particularly effective
actually we have the same way to trigger
in these illusions on let's say a full
fully blown focus and context set up
right and they're nowhere nearly as
interesting because that's a virtual
world you don't really care so much what
happens there what's effective in these
cases is in this in this ripple example
is that you know that your furniture
should not be moving your brain is very
sure of that otherwise things are not
right but it's something is happening so
when they do visually move and your
brain is still focused on the screen you
don't really see the discrepancies that
much between the projected and the real
ends up being quite a powerful illusion
we played with lots of other ones when
you think tilts when you're making
corners and all sorts of fun stuff and
all
them are really really powerful
especially if you're focused on the game
right because you just perceptually you
know that stuff should be very solid
this should not be moving and it ends up
messing you up another one is a
completely virtual kind of effects like
you know you can def a hold of that
collusion right you and again these are
just blue lines projected on the
background nothing fancy about that but
if they are tightly matched in motion to
whatever happens on the screen they're
powerful here is a star-filled think
about having a star game where all
you're doing this we actually put this
in conjunction with the program called
worldwide telescope where you're
exploring stars and even though the
white dots are completely randomly
generated white dots that are just there
the immersion level is amazing yours all
of them you feel like in this you know
you're in this planetarium experience
even though it's just your living room
this is a car game that you kind of
asked about in this case we only stole
the lighting from a game so the lighting
in the shadows is completely synthetic
but the car the you know the furniture
is real so it's just imagine you're
driving through a tunnel you're driving
through some overhead lights literally
all the shadows are simulated from the
geometry that we have everything is kind
of simulated at runtime but it
corresponds again accordingly to there
and you kind of see the extra car there
the discussion always that some people
think the shadow should follow the car
and some people think the shadow should
follow where you are you know five
meters behind the car and that actually
ends up affecting the lighting so it's a
kind of open to the debate but you know
I think that those are some of the game
design choices not necessarily
technology choices you can render them
whatever you want to here's an
interesting one where the illusion is
completely artificial it's snow illusion
is again white balls falling down but
one tightly matched the content of the
game is quite powerful so in this case
we have a car racer game notice the
snowflakes cannot actually go through
your wall or your furniture they kind of
end up accumulating back now if you
start driving forward they start rolling
towards you also the longer you drive
this game the more white you can make
the horizontal surfaces you know the
snow accumulates also sagoo fee things
like that and before you know what you
have little
is riding riding through it and trying
to pick up snowflakes and not really
paying attention to the game which is
exactly what you want to do with the
assistance that actually kind of means
the system is working you are having a
lot of fun lastly I think I'll show you
this one which is the idea that the
content can literally escape the TV and
we here we use the same content in the
same physics this is just a canned
example but you have a grenade falling
odd maybe hits your bookshelf hits your
floor roll is underneath your coffee
table now you might want to pick it up
and throw it back in the game before it
blows up or you might want to wait and
see how your furniture shakes right
either way it's fine all right so let's
talk about something that Michael
brought up before which is how do you
actually drive this Lucius how do you
get to the content how you get to the
emotional stuff and we in this paper
look whether all of these are papers
right you can always look up more stuff
online about this but up in this one we
explored three fundamentally different
ways one is ideally you're working with
the game ideally you have source code
access and you're working with the game
and in that case is actually not that
difficult to make the game double render
right or render certain things and into
all you do is you you have the same
rendering logic as your they have in the
game all you're doing the second one
where you set up a camera with a wider
field of view and make the same
rendering out there or use call certain
things out of that rendering if you want
some selective parts now but that
doesn't require you to hack the game
basically which is what we did with a
couple of these games we also drive a
lot of these illusions completely
synthetically from the vision of what
happens to happen on the screen so
here's the game on the on the side and
we run optical flow on it and then we
drive the kind of hole that collusions
or the starfield illusions of snow
illusions based on that kind of a motion
in the scene we also can intercept your
controls a lot of controls are very kind
of straightforward to take like you just
hack the controller get the controls and
map them directly to that to your
experience in a little you I you kind of
connect the inputs the outputs and you
can they actually think about that is
being kind of pre-scripted you get that
with the game for the games that don't
necessarily allow you to scrape their
content out so there's multiple ways of
triggering this stuff and we also looked
at beyond gaming we looked at the
different ways that you can set up
illumiroom setups for other kinds of
content so we created a little vignette
videos that look at sports and you know
fashion and also some kind of music
video type things and here's like just a
little bit this is a for those who know
this is eric Horvitz is a hockey game
you are a bike ride there or have a
fashion show where you kind of have a
lot of trippy visuals on the side and it
becomes really interesting when you have
different content the content that
doesn't exactly match it's not just an
extension of content but content that
just draws your eyes to it or something
happens right we would love to have the
ideas of you know you're watching an NFL
game and a quarterback throws the throw
the the focus really focuses and pans
around and you know is there but you're
also seeing the fans and the
cheerleaders and the opposing fans
booing and all that kind of stuff in the
periphery and it becomes a much more
interesting experience so the way the
way the way that I started thinking
about this space recently is it's kind
of in this big closed loop where you
have but connect enabled and arguably it
is really a revolutionary product
because in took the took technology that
was really difficult to obtain an
expensive and kind of lab driven to kind
of masses but connect literally allowed
you to transport yourself into the game
all of a sudden you can become an avatar
you can impact the game your emotions
your dances your you know whatever kind
of movements can become part of the data
the game experience what illumiroom is
is trying to do and what some of these
projects that I talk to you about today
are trying to do is literally do the
opposite complete the loop so that take
the game experiences and adapted to your
space make that more relevant to where
you live and how you live so that you
can literally not just always have to
teleport yourself into a different world
the game can come back back there and
game can be adaptive to the to your
particular environment it also means
that if you change your environment the
game should adapt there but that is kind
of that's the that's the bonus in many
cases it's difficult case but it's it's
a lot of fun because you don't have to
play the same experience all the time
so again all of these experiences were
enabled with a depth sensing camera
connecting this case or precursor to
connect or whatever and a projector but
I do want to stress that the the the
ideas are in many ways transcend this
idea of projection basic mended reality
they're not just spatial augmented
reality they are also augmented reality
in a general case a lot of them can be
applied to a head where headworn
displays or other forms of augmentation
so I'll leave you with this idea that we
will be able to transform I firmly
believe that pretty much anything around
us into kind of industry interactive
display just the challenges like how do
you actually interact with it once it's
everywhere once every single pixel is
addressable and there this does not mean
that we're gonna I'm not arguing that
the existing input devices or existing
displays are going away I think there's
lots of uses for the phone as I told you
the beginning I actually worked on mice
and keyboards I don't think that are
going away either I think it's really
about extending what our interaction Bob
you Larry is extending the bandwidth of
options and how we interact with
computers is not so much about we're
going to be replacing the existing
devices I think we're just going to
complement them and extend them in their
interesting ways so I want to thank my
collaborators there's a bunch of folks
who are just fantastic to work with and
at this point I'll just takes them from
your questions thank
yeah so in a lot of the best examples
you were showing of you know dragging
people in the light if they're stole
like a little bit of an agency like this
is tomorrow things yes like what's the
biggest challenge what was your biggest
challenge to get it to the low latency
already have it yeah what would it take
that's a great question so there's
couple answers that we have about this a
latency is a big killer in all of these
systems and to end latency and most of
these projection systems are on the
order of 100 milliseconds that is if you
don't introduce even even a slightest
bit of computation what you're really
doing is camera is capturing you
transfer it over you know USB you get
there you display that same image back
out through the projector and the
end-to-end latency in there is about 100
milliseconds that is enough that if you
have a moving object if you move your
hand like you know meter a second you're
like the thing is off your hand so it's
a big problem I think fundamentally it's
a problem that most people in the
industry are well aware of and there's
there's lots of work recently that there
is there there's also a really
interesting paper but Albert and and
Paul deets about measuring latency and
having going down they found out that
that people are contrary to popular
belief we can really easily detect
latency down to even one millisecond but
what's really more interesting about
that particular work to me is that the
way that the low latency systems the way
that they make you feel is this is a
fundamental shift once you get down sub
10 10 milliseconds like the so for
people who don't know about that system
it was basically an inking system where
you draw you move your finger down and
it just ends up drawing ink behind it
and they look and introduce marrying
varying different different Layton sees
to give you a perception of how it feels
with latency in there so once you get
down to like five milliseconds and 10
milliseconds you fundamentally go from
believing that this is a device that
renders your stroke to believing that
there's paint coming out of your finger
literally kind of feels of that it's
fundamentally different and it's hard to
display its card to describe but that's
kind of what it is I think that that's
really interesting speaking in our
systems what
we try to do we of course try to
optimize our code and things like that
but there's not much we can do with
commercial level kind of Kinect sensor
right now or with commercial level
projectors with mostly buffer at least
one frame if not more to do this but I
think we had several several projects
some of them we've done this summer as
well as hopefully they'll appear some of
the conferences where we looked at we
looked at different approaches for
predicting motion because a lot of these
motions are actually very predictable if
the ball is in midair you know you're
only governed by laws of gravity you can
completely extrapolate their post
positions and and correct for
projections to do that if the if the
motions of the hands are you know there
you can use kinematics and kind of try
to maybe look up previous look at
previous likely positions and what the
next likely positions in your next next
couple frames are in there so I think
there's approaches to combat latency
even kind of purely in the software side
that really haven't been played out yet
we started to scratch the surface there
but ultimately I think it requires kind
of everything to come together I think
it it's it's one of those brute-force
approaches that you need to optimize
every single part to get it down to you
know 15 milliseconds or less riddles yes
it's very it's very format the nice
thing about some of these systems though
is um so for example illumiroom or all
the be mature and things of that unless
you're projecting on humans or highly
moving objects most of the room for the
most part is actually very static so
there you kind of control all the
aspects of it and and and that's
actually when people ask me kind of
compare and contrast I put headworn
displays and projection based displays
that's actually one of the big selling
big benefits of these projection
displays is that our immersive setups
are our augmentations are rock solid on
the static jam on this geometry room in
in a headworn system unless you get
latency down to like really low levels
like sub 5 mil is 5 milliseconds things
you're always going to notice this
jitter and lag and things are never
quite aligned things are not rock solid
the way that these illusions like the
way that the the wobble illusion and all
this stuff works is because it's it's
pixel rock solid
on their thing and when it starts
shaking and moving all of a sudden you
realize holy holy crap this is this is
not the real anymore this is not a
college supposed to be if it was
wobbling all the time doing this
illusion it just doesn't work it's just
like yes you can you can run the same
shader code on that but it's just
nowhere nearly as effective yeah any
more questions outside are you joking
with the military or any of the systems
for pilots you mean my head's up this
place well beyond because of the scams
like over this way like me and 35 yes I
am not right now I at Microsoft Research
we don't engage mark with DoD and things
that my my primary when I was doing a
PhD I worked with Steve I nerd Columbia
we'd worked with a lot with Office of
Naval Research and lots of heads-up
displays they're also tank turrets for
for tank commanders things like that and
again I think those are very
complimentary interesting challenges but
at this point we haven't worked with
with the DoD or anything like that I'm
well familiar with it with the field but
I'm not involved what we definitely
spoke with I mean I keep in touch with a
lot of those folks still but we're we're
mostly focused in the consumer kind of
lightweight gaming productivity
applications things like that things of
that are kind of a focus for Microsoft
right now I've heard there's lots of
lots of problems with the f-35 helmets
and things of that so I and a lot of
them have to deal with this lag and
field of view and just complexity and
reliability of these systems / or a long
time I think that's a those are really
challenging some really good challenges
yes pizza a speculative question now
looking at the cat all the challenges
that you faced with this kind of work
get Deacon suspended one law of physics
essentially if you could just magically
solve one of the problems you have to do
with whether it's sort of how brightly
you can pledge I flied out into the
world so that you can get outside of
caves and these kinds of things what is
it that you would really want it to fix
or to change that would enable that next
layer of interaction that's a very good
question i mean i think there's a lot of
them i write this is definitely
something that is really interesting to
us I so i really like laser projectors
for a couple particular reasons one is
that they don't require focus and that
you know you can basically shine them
out and images and focus from here to
infinity right if they're really
collimated laser projectors however I
look at the trend of the increasing
brightness for some of these projections
and granted they're they're working on
limited power budgets in terms of their
all are trying to focus to be a laser
projector for the phone all the
companies and things of that but still
like the trajectory of increasing lumens
output of these projectors is is very
slow and and to overpower this for the
longer term is not case but the bright
projectors are all basically little
fridges right there they're kind of a
they require a lot of stuff and
primarily the heating and the light
source and kind of how do you get all
that stuff out of there solving that
would be really kind of instrumental in
that case because it would enable you to
to shrink things down right now it's
there's this kind of low power low
lumens small package thing and
high-power high lumens thing and a lot
of the really interesting application
would be with you had a pipe basically
high lumens but small package set up the
rooms are in part of right yeah i mean
here your we're getting to the point
where depth cameras i mean most most
people think you know def camera connect
and but the reason why i connect is so
wide is there's two reasons why is it
has an erase terrible array microphone
that kind of has four different points
so there's there's a distance between
each of these microphones and also
there's a distance between the two the
projector and the camera there's about
10 centimeters of that so it ends up
being a bar
but right now with the time-of-flight
cameras and especially ones that are on
the market or their prototype stage like
the PMD ones or self kinetic or Canasta
ones that are that are built into the
new kinect those are all fundamentally
they can be rather small I mean they're
their devices right now that are about a
centimeter two centimeter small so the
sensing part of this whole equation is
actually getting miniaturized the
projector part is not quite there
you